Wendy Williams the talk-show host says
her battle with Graves disease has
knocked her off the air it's so good to
talk to you will you take care of
yourself don't talk to me like I'm sick
you take care of yourself Wendy said
that just three weeks ago and now day
two of her show being a rerun her
producers say she's taking a hiatus
because her Graves disease is causing
fatigue she will be quote taking some
time off as she continues to receive
treatment sorry
big we've seen Wendy struggle before in
2017 she collapsed on live TV due to
dehydration
it was the 55 year old has also shown
symptoms of her immune disorder on her
show including anxiety and bulging eyes
Wendy made it clear she's not a fan of
hosting her show from home you're not up
with this why not I give so much during
my show of myself that the one place
that I've always been able to count on
to be my own secret little place is home
and now you're home and more talk show
news Ryan Seacrest on the men and upbeat
with Kelly today
good morning Wednesday May 20th Ryan's
reps denied he suffered a stroke after
one of his eyes was shut halfway and he
had slurred speech during the big live
finale of American Idol Cynthia areevo
and the top 11 right there the hosts
worth a estimated 330 million dollars
explained the moment and also all the
very kind of well wishes from my
exhaustion working around the clock so I
got a day off to relax Ryan seemed to be
feeling V work from home pressure cooker
when Rachel talked to him two weeks ago
but you know it's been not busy I'm
working in the same room doing four
shows so it's like every single corner
of this room has cameras or a microphone
in it but Ryan's actually a pro at the
quick bounce back after this Idol stage
dive in 2011 he didn't miss a beat and
remember this fall at the beginning of
the year
[Applause]
Ryann tumbled in his chair on live TV
but quickly recovered
[Applause]
[Music]